Jo.
Quantum circuit bude jednotkou hodnoty
pro tvůj byznys — qubit je jednotkou informace,
ale circuit je jednotkou výpočtu.
Tak se pojďme podívat, co to vlastně quantum circuit je,
a proberme jeho anatomii.
Takhle vypadá quantum circuit —
skládá se z částí: qubity
jsou znázorněny těmito vodorovnými čárami, v tomto případě zobrazujeme
circuit, který má čtyři qubity, jak tady vidíš.
Teď — gates jsou
způsob, jak řídíme qubity,
a gates čteš zleva doprava.
Single-qubit gates můžou být jednodušší
single-qubit gates nebo multi-qubit gates.
Tam vidíš controlled gate —
to je ta, která má čáru mezi dvěma qubity,
a tam se odehraje entangling operace.
A nakonec máš měření a klasický výstup.
A velmi důležitě — circuit spouštíš mnohokrát,
abys dostal výsledek — k tomu slouží pojem shots.
Shot counter je počet opakování,
kolikrát musíš výpočet zopakovat, abys dostal výsledek.
Tak
jak vypadají?
Podívejme se, jak vypadá dvoubitový — je to jako
ten obrázek, co jsem ukazoval předtím, představující změnu fáze,
a ukázal jsem operaci, která provedla tuto rotaci
a umožňuje provést tu interferenční operaci.
Tak si udělejme srovnání mezi klasickým circuit
a quantum circuit — u klasického circuit tady
uvidíš, že tam žádné modré měsíce nejsou,
žádné rotace, všechno je tu růžové,
a máš pouze jednotlivé stavy,
které v těchhle gates vidíme v oknech.
Ale všimni si, jak velký kontrast to bude,
když skutečně implementujeme quantum circuit.
To jsou skutečné circuits, které spouštíme na našich kvantových počítačích —
a můžeš je taky vyzkoušet.
Circuits, které budeme vytvářet
kombinací gates,
generují plnou komplexní amplitudu —
ten obrázek, který jsem s vámi sdílel
dříve. Proč je to důležité?
Protože teď můžeme generovat tyhle komplexní vztahy
mezi qubity z hlediska fází
a entanglementu a pak skrz akt měření
jsme schopni zkolabovat toto obrovské množství
výpočtu, který probíhá uvnitř, do
nějaké důležité odpovědi.
A tak se nakonec dostaneme
k té odpovědi — dáme je vedle sebe, jen vizuálně,
a můžeš vycítit, že klasický circuit
nikdy nemůže využít obrovský výpočetní prostor,
který quantum circuit dokáže využít.
Tyhle vizualizace ti dávají intuici
o bohatosti, se kterou můžeme přistupovat k tomuto velkému stavovému prostoru.
A krásná věc na tom je, že můžeme mít
mnoho tříd circuits pro
různé funkce. Takže
třeba toto je circuit,
který je navržen k modelování finančního rizika.
Tady je příklad circuit,
který se používá pro vyhledávání a optimalizaci problémů.
A tady je příklad circuit, který se používá k
simulaci molekuly. Důležité
zjištění je, že pro různé aplikace
můžeš navrhovat různé circuits.
Circuits, které navrhujeme, jsou pak zachyceny
v softwaru a uchovávány jako software,
a v našem případě je uchováváme v Qiskit,
což je náš open-source vývojový kit pro kvantové počítání.
Je to jeden z nejrozšířenějších
softwarových frameworků pro kvantové počítání.
A můžeš si představit, jak buduješ
knihovny circuits, které se vkládají do
klasických programů, které teď kombinují to nejlepší z klasického programování
a to nejlepší z kvantového výkonu.